I'm not giving up on my family
[Music]
so happy at you're here after my parents
died and I didn't really think I was
gonna be able to come back to Tijuana
but you always made me feel like family
you are my family
[Music]
I'm Erik Alma's handler I just want to
find my friend I need you to do a favor
for me first
you mess around I'll kill you both
park the car real close to the car
this is you you have to believe me they
made me do it the building that you blew
up the DEA safe house you know how long
you go away for unless you help us get
Menino Esparza
see
forget your friend and who's coming to
save you
whether or not you survive
it's entirely up to you
you're gonna be my you gotta learn how
to use one of these a viola bullet
balleseros everything ever since you
showed up the police in one step ahead
you better do what you need to do Toledo
he has a mole in his operation
I'm gonna come back
I'm not giving up on my family
La Bella
in the end
the bullet settles everything
[Music]
you